1916, only 13 years after the Wright brothers
flew the first heavier-than-air aircraft,
an American company was established, ready to
revolutionize the fledgling aviation industry.
Founded as Pacific Aero Products and
renamed just a year later as Boeing,
the company enjoyed decades of success and
developed some of the best technologies
and many of the best aircraft of the time.
From the first modern commercial airliner,
the Boeing 247, launched in 1933, to the iconic
Jumbo 747, Boeing was able to amaze humankind
for decades... until Airbus came along that is.
90 years after the launch of the iconic Boeing
247, the world of aviation today is radically
different. Not only does Boeing no longer lead
the market, it has been overtaken by a
competitor almost half its age: Airbus.
Take a look at this graph.
What you see is a hard-fought war,
a market divided between two giants where Airbus
is now in the lead. And it has been for most of
the past 20 years, Europe's Airbus has recorded
more orders than its North American rival.
The question is, why? How is it possible that
the Europeans have managed to beat the mighty
American commercial aviation industry?
Many of you may be thinking that this
change has a lot to do with the Boeing 737
MAX fiasco, a plane that was grounded for 20
months because air safety authorities banned
it from flying after two fatal crashes.
And yes, in a way this has a lot to do
with what happened, after all, the 737
Max was Boeing's great hope. Although we are not
going to delve too much into this matter because
we have already made a video entirely dedicated
to this topic here on VisualPolitik. I’ll leave
the link at the end of the video.
But no, that's not the only reason
why Airbus has managed to overtake its US rival.
In this case, the story goes back much further.
Have you ever wondered how on earth a European
aircraft company managed to catch
up, in quality and technology,
with the great American leader that controlled
this industry practically from the start?
How did Airbus come into being, whose
idea was it and why was it created,
and who put up the money to make it look
like a rival for Boeing? And perhaps the
most important question of all: What on earth
does all this have to do with VisualPolitik?
VisualPolitik viewers, the story of Airbus
and its war with Boeing is more than a story
of competition between two companies, it
is also a story of political competition:
the United States versus the European
Union. The old giant versus the new titan.
And believe me when I tell you that there are a
lot, and I mean a lot of layers in this one. This
is a story that goes far beyond aviation itself.
So... Are you ready? Are your seat belts fastened?
Well... Let's get started.
(UNITY IS
STRENGTH)
The second half of the 20th century
was the era of economic explosion and
modernity both in the West and in much of Asia.
And it was also the time when Europe was rising
from the ashes of World War Two. Where once
there had been constant fighting and conflict,
now suddenly there was agreement and cooperation.
In fact, if this had not been the case,
Airbus would probably never have existed.
The European aeronautics company par excellence
was launched in 1970. It was the result of a
political negotiation between governments
that had already begun a few years earlier.
Yes, that’s right. Airbus was not
the brainchild of some visionary
entrepreneur or anything like that.
The idea came from the offices of the
French and West German governments
in the late 1960s. To achieve this,
these governments encouraged the union of the
French aeronautical company, Aerospatiale,
with the German company, Deutsche Airbus. The
consortium was later joined by aeronautical
companies from Spain and the United Kingdom.
In essence, the idea was to replicate the
collaboration that the French and the British had
undertaken to create Concorde a few years earlier,
but in this case with the objective of
creating a long-term structure that would
make it possible to make aircraft that
were, shall we say, less exclusive.
Aircraft that first had to be able to
fill a gap in which the American Boeing,
Lockheed and McDonnell Douglas, which completed
about 80% of the market, had no product. And later
to compete with them, directly, on a large scale.
And so it is that the first aircraft to be
launched was the Airbus A300, which was the
first wide-body aircraft to make commercial
flights with two engines under ETOPS standards.
But, let's not get sidetracked and let's get into
the situation.
With the
Europeans manufacturing modern aircraft and
gradually gaining more and more market share
thanks to the merger of several companies,
Boeing had to do something. So in 1997 it
tried to replicate the model by acquiring
its direct US competitor, McDonnell Douglas.
However, with this purchase, the American
giant inherited some of the company’s problems,
including economic and corporate culture problems
that would sooner or later take their toll.
Be that as it may, the fact is that the era of
what is perhaps the most important and powerful
duopoly of all had begun: that of aviation.
Now, let's not go too fast. This is an industry
that requires a lot of capital investment,
that is, to make it work you have to put
in a lot of money. As you can imagine, designing,
developing and manufacturing aircraft is not easy.
The question is: Who was going to put up the money
to develop the technology that would allow each of
the two companies to try to conquer the market?
For the first time, Boeing had a potential giant
in front of it, capable of looking at them eye to
eye, but how exactly would they compete? How did
the Europeans intend to eclipse the US giant?
Well, you see, let me say it again,
in order to launch a new program, to create a
new airplane, two things are needed above all:
the first is money, lots and lots of money.
But to give you a clearer idea of what we are
talking about, let's take a concrete example,
let's take a look at the case of Airbus A380,
the world's largest airliner, which was
discontinued in March 2021 when the last
aircraft left the factory.
Well, take a look.
The A380 program, which includes the entire
development cycle from conceptual idea to entry
into service, was initially estimated
in 2000 to cost about $11.3 billion.
However, estimates today point to the
development of this giant of the skies
swallowing up more than $30 billion.
These are astronomical figures. And,
keep in mind that Airbus itself acknowledges
that the A380 has never made a profit. Well,
it is not that it has not generated profits, but
that billions of dollars were lost along the way.
And this is where we come to the
second thing you need to launch a
new aircraft. In addition to money, there
obviously needs to be sufficient demand.
Given the numbers involved,
poor forecasts could turn the
development of the new aircraft into a disaster.
Well, right here we come to the most controversial
part of this duel of titans. The question is,
what has Airbus done better than the Americans?
From the point of view of many Americans, what
Europe has done with Airbus is nothing short of
unfair competition. A situation that even provoked
a trade war between the United States and the
European bloc. Take a look.
(U.S. and EU Agree to
Suspend Airbus-Boeing Trade Fight
The 17-year trade fight is the longest and most
costly in the history of the WTO. U.S. importers
have paid more than $1.1 billion of tariffs
since the duties in the dispute took effect in
2019, according to data from U.S. Customs and
Border Protection. – Wall Street Journal)
Now, do you want to know exactly what this
conflict is about and why it has occurred?
Has Airbus really grown thanks to favored
treatment from European governments? Has this
been a case of unfair competition? And what
about the United States?
Well, let's take a look.
(WAR OF EGOS)
The trade dispute between the United States and
the European Union, and between Boeing and Airbus,
with the World Trade Organization in the middle,
had one very clear cause: financing.
You see, Airbus, the European aircraft
manufacturer, has been receiving huge amounts
of public money since its inception to meet
the costs of developing new aircraft.
But let's look at a few facts. Throughout
the history of the consortium, the
governments of France, Germany,
the United Kingdom and Spain, later joined
by others, have injected tons of cash.
Money in the form of both direct subsidies and
loans at artificially low interest rates or,
directly, without any financial
cost, that is, without interest.
We are talking about aid that
could exceed 15 billion dollars,
but whose impact on the market
could, according to some estimates,
be in the region of 200 billion
dollars, all of which, logically,
works against Boeing in the United States.
All this funding is what is known as "launch
aid" and forms one of the largest industrial
policy plans in Europe in recent decades.
Basically, the European States used these tools
to cover a significant part of the cost of the
development of the first Airbus models, such as
the A300 or the mid-size aircraft family, such as
the A320, which competes with the Boeing 737.
The conflict arises because, initially,
the idea was that these subsidies would be reduced
until they disappeared as Airbus matured in the
market. And also because they would have to be
repaid in full as each program made a profit.
In other words, the company was to
be supported with European taxpayers'
money as it took off with the expectation of
returning a higher profit down the track.
Basically, a typical industrial policy plan,
which I am sure many of you would consider
favorably. After all, Airbus was a success and,
well, you may also think that it is better to
devote public resources to initiatives like this
one rather than to other types of... Let's say
more abstract, less productive causes.
Of course, there would be a lot to say
about this matter, but that is more a topic
for our sister channel, VisualEconomik.
In any case, as you can imagine, the Americans
are not happy about it. And even less so if we
take into account that this financial
aid didn’t end up disappearing nor has
Airbus repaid the totality of these loans.
(6 March 2019: Airbus In Dispute Over $600m
Of Unpaid Loans Used To Develop The A380
According to Reuters, Airbus claims that "it
would no longer need to repay any outstanding
state loans on the A380 because governments
had agreed to share risk in the roughly
15-billion-euro project." – Simple Flying)
As you can see, these "launch aids" were so
advantageous that they apparently included a
clause whereby, if the program went wrong,
the risk was shared between the lenders,
that is governments, and the recipient: Airbus. In
other words, both would share the losses... Which,
by the way, does not happen with the profits.
In fact, it's not like Airbus is losing money.
Yes, the A380 program went badly, but the company
is going from strength to strength. For example,
in 2022, this company posted a net profit, that
means after tax, of more than 4.2 billion euros,
the best result in its entire history.
Despite this, part of the losses on the
A380 program have been absorbed
by the European countries.
[And to tell you the truth, I
don't know if this makes sense].
But what is clear is that the Americans don't
like it one bit. The anger is monumental.
Both at Boeing headquarters and
among politicians in Washington.
In their view, the Europeans have been torpedoing
their aircraft industry with alleged illegal aid.
And in fact, the World Trade Organization
went so far as to rule that such loans to
Airbus generated unfair competition. So,
what can I say, they did have a point.
In order to make peace with Washington and
comply with WTO guidelines, the European Union,
France and Spain had to raise the interest
rates charged to Airbus for loans linked to
the launch of the A350, one of the European
manufacturer's new flagship programs.
Now then, stop, let’s put the brakes
on. Before you tip the scales in favor
of one or the other, wait a bit because
as we usually insist on VisualPolitik...
every story has at least two versions.
And it’s not exactly as if the Americans
have been behaving above board. Not at all.
In fact, we could even say that the US
government has bailed Boeing out of a lot of
trouble in recent years, and it has done so
in a number of different ways. Some of them,
by the way, with catastrophic consequences.
Do you want to know what exactly we are talking
about? Do you want to know what tricks the
Americans got up to? Well... Pay attention!
(BAILOUTS… UNDER THE TABLE?)
We have already told you that Airbus has received
a lot of money from European taxpayers. Debts that
on many occasions have been forgiven, which
has clearly harmed Boeing in its competition
with Airbus, but... What about the Americans?
Have they stood by with their arms folded?
Well, obviously not. There are some winners
and losers in this story. Boeing has also been
receiving billions of dollars in US government
funding and for many, huge sweetheart deals.
Favorable treatment, which is reported
to have come at times from the US Federal
Aviation Agency itself, the until recently highly
respected FAA, the agency in charge of regulating
and overseeing all activities related to civil
aviation and its safety in the United States.
The question is... How did they do it? Well, you
see, the way the United States has – and continues
to – fund Boeing is through multi-billion
dollar military and aerospace contracts, which
many believe are awarded, with inflated prices.
In other words, as a kind of hidden subsidy.
In fact, look at the data: Boeing's largest
contractors are none other than NASA,
the US Department of Defense and the
US Department of Homeland Security.
In 2017 alone Boeing earned $23.4 billion in US
government contracts, according to data compiled
from the General Services Administration.
And in fact, in its defense, Airbus claims
that the constant and numerous
contracts Boeing receives from the
US government and public agencies are a way
of subsidizing the American aviation giant.
But not only that, there is also the alleged
favorable treatment by the FAA that we were
telling you about a moment ago. Take a look.
(FAA saw high risk of crashes, but let Boeing
737 MAX keep flying – The Seattle Times)
([The Boeing 737 MAX crashes] "were the
horrific culmination of a series of faulty
technical assumptions by Boeing's engineers,
a lack of transparency on the part of Boeing's
management, and grossly insufficient oversight
by the FAA" – Report of Transportation
and Infrastructure Committee of the United
States House of Representatives)
(FAA and Boeing manipulated 737
Max tests during recertification – The Verge)
In fact, all indications are that, in addition
to the money that the United States injects into
Boeing every year through contracts, it was also
helping the company by providing it with certain
laxity when it came to certifying its airplanes.
Specifically, the case of the 737 MAX, which
was an aircraft that was designed late and
poorly to compete with the Airbus A320neo,
which was launched practically by surprise
and against which Boeing found itself
out of the market and unable to compete.
If these suspicions are confirmed, what we
can say is that the outcome was tragic.
But hold on because we haven't
told you about tax incentives yet.
(12 March 2020: Washington state
repeals pro-Boeing tax break;
U.S. hopes to avoid EU tariffs
The changes would remove the 40%
savings on Business and Occupation tax, which
saved Boeing some $118 million in 2018 based
on published jetliner revenues. – Reuters)
Are these provisions not public subsidies
that also harm free competition, and
are they not favoritism on the part of
US administrations towards Boeing?
Well... the truth is that the World
Trade Organization not only ruled against
Airbus, it also ruled against the Americans.
(WTO rules US failed to stop
unfair tax break to Boeing
The US had not enforced an order in 2012
to stop subsidies to the US aircraft maker
through Washington state tax breaks. The undue
competitive advantage led to lost sales of Airbus'
A320neo and A320ceo single-aisle aircraft
in five sales campaigns. – Financial Times)
So, what can I say? Both giants are guilty of
doing the same thing but in different ways.
This is a story in which there are neither good
guys nor bad guys... But at ground level there
are big, "suckers": the taxpayers.
Because yes, it may be reasonable
to support the development of large
technological and industrial projects,
but perhaps the aid should be fairer, limited
and open to more companies, don't you think?
The fact is that signing a trade peace agreement
on this issue between the United States and Europe
has not been easy, nor has it been something that
fell from the sky. What's more, there has been
one factor that has played a key role in the end
of the war between the two companies and the two
blocks. Can you guess what it could be?
Well... Listen up.
(WHAT CHINA HAS JOINED TOGETHER,
LET NO MAN PUT ASUNDER)
Seventeen years of war between the world's
two leading aircraft companies takes its toll.
In the end it's something we
repeat a lot on VisualPolitik:
trade wars don't usually benefit either side. And
the case of Boeing and Airbus is no different.
Both manufacturers have been hurting each
other... And by extension may have been
hurting the development of the industry.
The fight between the United States and
the European Union raised import and export costs,
restricted the use and development of technologies
and ultimately made aircraft more expensive
and slowed the evolution of the industry.
And do you know what? This created
an ideal breeding ground for others
to try to take advantage of the troubled
waters. Now the wolf's ears are in view.
And yes, the wolf is, once again, China.
("We also agreed to work together [EU & U.S.]
to challenge and counter China's non-market
practices in this sector that give China's
companies an unfair advantage." – Joe Biden)
As we also told you in a past video in our
dedicated series of videos on the world of
aviation, the Airbus-Boeing duopoly could be
threatened, at least in the short and medium-haul
segment, by a new competitor: China's COMAC.
Beijing is aggressively using a mix of
the two forms of public subsidies we
have seen in this video, those used by the
Europeans and those used by the Americans.
The Chinese government is directly subsidizing
aircraft development, and is also placing huge
orders through its state-owned airlines.
In fact, the COMAC ARJ21, which can carry
up to 100 passengers, is already flying
commercially, and the COMAC C919 is currently
on its initial commercial introduction.
Although it has encountered some problems
and its entry into service may be
delayed from the 2023 schedule,
the fact remains that this aircraft may pose a
huge threat to the future of Boeing and Airbus.
We are talking about an aircraft that can carry
up to 174 passengers and therefore competes
directly with the A320 and 737 in China, the
flagships of the two Western giants. What's more,
China expects to manufacture 150 of
these aircraft per year by 2028.
And this scenario, that of an aircraft
manufacturer for the Chinese short-
and medium-haul market, would be the
worst nightmare for Airbus and Boeing.
Why? Because China is the key market for the
future of the two aviation giants. In fact,
according to Boeing's own calculations, the Asian
giant will need to buy, wait for it, almost 8,500
new passenger aircraft between now and 2041.
This is a real payday, and if a local competitor
such as COMAC manages to take even
a significant slice of this pie,
the future of Boeing and Airbus could change
completely. A direct hit to the business.
So both companies – and the governments of the
United States and the European Union – have been
pragmatic. In recent years, both companies have
opened final assembly lines in China for some of
their most sought-after models, such as the
Boeing 737 or the Airbus A320 and A321neo.
In addition, the European Union has suggested to
the United States that they will end the so-called
"launch aid" to Airbus, in exchange for financing
the consortium through military spending.
Something we are already seeing. Check it out.
(Spain to lend Airbus 2.14 bln euros for
military programmes – Reuters)
Yes, as many of you may be thinking,
this is practically adopting the American
model of financing Boeing that Brussels
has been fighting against for 17 years.
[Well, it’s not exactly unheard of for
European politicians to change their tune...].
What is known so far is that both blocs,
the EU and the US, have signed a truce,
a ceasefire in this trade war, which in
theory should be resolved before 2026.
The future? Well, we can't know for sure,
but what is clear is that neither Airbus
nor Boeing is in a position to complain
too much about unfair competition.
The two industrial giants have received
enormous amounts of money, both control
more or less a similar share of the market,
and both have enormous political
connections with the public sector.
But now it's your turn: do you think Airbus and
Boeing will make peace for good? Should the two
companies start working together to prevent the
Chinese from gaining a foothold in the market?
What do you think the war for control of the
skies may look like in the coming decades?
Leave us your thoughts below in the comments.
Remember also that if you like what we do you can
support us by joining our community in Patreon
in one of the six different options we have.
Once again, thank you very much for being
there. All the best and see you next time.